So, a couple of tips. Number 1: The Business Model Canvas
is a scorecard; it's not the class.
The lectures are not the class.
We're not asking you, as facilitators or mentors, to lecture in the class
but to do short summaries just to make sure everybody's up to speed
and ask probing questions to spur conversation.
But the class itself is about critiques about each team's findings,
from their original hypotheses to what did they actually learn.
One of the things we do to make the teams feel great
is when someone actually gets physically thrown out of a customer,
just remind students that some of the most aggressive teams
seem to be actually spending their time trying to get customer data
sometimes have been known to get thrown out of buildings because they've been so aggressive
or threatened with arrest because they shouldn't be where they are.
We're not asking you to break any laws or do anything illegal.
But you know you're pushing hard when somebody physically grabs you by the arm
and escorts you out of a place.
Then you get in--then you get to show up at the class, tell us that story,
and the teaching team needs to stand up and applaud that activity.
That just means there was an aggressive team.
And just remind them that we do not provide bail
or political asylum, depending on your country.
But being passive is not the way to actually proceed with this class.